how's it going as my spirit pad welcome
back
really I miss you so much it's been a
split second for me let's keep playing
this is a lot creepier smize EMM Nisha
hello this is very [ __ ] creepy
Oh God Shh shut up and hug me [ __ ] when
is that a doorknob how the hell is tree
growing here that doesn't make any sense
I bet it better not break that vase oh
god Emma can't
this must be dad's office could that be
it dad dad it's your Nana
I'm here to blab blab okay because
nothing up here
what are you hustle please don't
patronize me
what are we possibly supposed to do with
that
memory maybe the next one is behind
those roots Oh Frank's it follows a
simple concept
wow that's pretty awesome
I like that all right it's going there
it's kind of straightforward once you
understand the concept behind it I think
I know your net it's okay
you're beautiful save compensates what's
up with this picture though
mrs. Gow it's probably not oh hello
conveniently-placed jack
that's an awesome chair by the way which
I had a chair like that I won't spill a
chair out of oatmeal it was not
comfortable but it was delicious so I'd
give it so better than that Kia chairs
that's something I know I'm Swedish and
I'm supposed to be all like okay it's
great but you know what it's not that
great Oh God the quality is pretty
mediocre and the prices are good but
then you go to your friends and house
and they're like oh we have the same
furniture and I'm like god dammit try to
be better
oh god they have alligators here cuz I'm
a peasant child egg is gonna be
alligator
alright the sign says go [ __ ] off so we
better [ __ ] off then oh god it's a door
yeah I knew that every every tree hasn't
drawn right I'll be silly
mind God there we go wonderful yeah the
meatballs at IKEA is [ __ ] delicious
though I'm sorry now I feel bad Swedish
meatballs so we did before is like the
only food we have from Sweden I feel bad
tap it dolly has like beef time pass and
Spanish it have like like in paella or
whatever in French advocates and
question
Benny shoe : the beer and the Germans
have the beer and the bat fish and the
German - inside the in the ocean JP
divide care and in the Porsche but
Sweden we have meatballs and we live
this meeples so [ __ ] much because
it's all we have
Oh God I think the alligators gonna come
after me that's ok I'm not an alligator
hater skater
I should have done that but I did it all
right
shouldn't we have to go in the water now
we don't have to I can't swim so it's
probably not a good idea
everything is very conveniently Oh God
Oh God
conveniently placed everything in his
right Bruges earners read sorry I just
love it oh I really feel like a baby
spire summer shoot is that the puzzle
puss hmm we found enough Clementine or
was it Katie yeah I liked Clementine
more so lyric lemme my I'm gonna get you
outta here clammy
don't you worry don't you worry child
this baby's got a place for you hmm
where are we oh we're back why of course
it all make sense and it's almost too
easy
um Clemmy I need you to cooperate then I
tell you to get the king what's your
Excuse
you're a centipede got good enough Gary
you're on your own how did we get out of
here huh got it
did I just step on climbing I think I
did I don't mean to me means the
climbing because she has the same name
with Clementine Bank you can't be a
[ __ ] for addressing your life let's go
through here right oh we're back now
we're out oh god the alligators then we
better hurry
crawl crawl to figure out it has great
atmosphere to this game it's really easy
to lose your baby nests in and I do feel
like a baby oh god if I don't I'm a man
am I talking about
I got scared of it same thing twice I
fight me I don't know why I keep doing
that in this weird sounding funny
no they hang don't look teddy oh god
what what that oh god what the Frank not
cool man it is kind of hard to get all
the pieces I gotta say well we survived
the alligator hater scary and we're back
what the painting changed back or not I
guess it won't let's hurry time is of
the essence
that's one would say as I would say
practically now this place feels yeah
let's not dwell here for too long the
feels one more baby
and then we can go forward it feels I
get you that has been catching up on
fanfiction that's the only way to get
the proper feels good this place it's
been left out for so long
Teddy what the [ __ ] does she do does she
hung herself she's no don't don't
why did I say hung myself I meant drown
god I'm so [ __ ] smart did you know
how you study math that's how smart I am
[ __ ] genius two plus two equals [ __ ]
that's all I know
this doesn't look like it's it I don't
know what I feel about this I don't know
what oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
we're dead what is that oh mama
hello I don't understand why it's okay
for boots goddamn boots are they even
Prada oh my god they're a cheap copy oh
my god this is [ __ ] disgrace how
could they
Slenderman
why does he want from me like what did I
ever do to him I thought we were cool
all right it looks like I need some
assistance here yes you will have to do
mr. J I didn't actually call it meant to
call you that now I feel bad okay
wonderful shows how far my brain goes
not very far that is all right we shall
have to go in here can i push you
oh what a frickin a [ __ ] it fro what
that is that I can't you love cars I say
it the hell you think I'm flying
maybe baby but I'm not playing oh yeah
God baby does not like we're [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't think that's a nice kind
of monster hello who drew that [ __ ]
ha sorry I'm on mushrooms
nothing up there okay so now we know we
can't get fun
Oh God why don't you bros oh god I hate
creepy misty forest assist right forest
forest is just this because you never
know what's gonna happen really do you
the puzzle piece I'm God
okay you know what just okay hope he
doesn't come oh oh I'm really bad at
this
don't come while I'm doing this
thank you oh god I think I can hear him
I am very very very very [ __ ] now oh
boy I better get this puzzle piece
how much longer oh god okay go and go
and pay I don't get it getting what that
[ __ ] alright I guess we go back I don't
think we can actually cuz we went down a
longish is the key all right
oh I wasn't so bad at all actually I'm
surprised I like my full myself Cory
what a what a complicated puzzle why oh
yeah I have to it's like that everywhere
no I'm that one thank you yeah I'm yeah
all right wonderful
still there teddy all right I love you
too Danny
mother of [ __ ] teddy
what is that atrocious to TT Teddy Oh
God
okay
all right it's just a horrible creature
that wants to tear me off good thing I'm
not a little baby in that I can't defend
it again hit me all right it looks too
obvious to go too isn't it
I better keep out
because I need a man no I don't I'm a
baby who can make me sad it Noah that's
gross I bet she bub can't even climb
there that doesn't make sense
the student that's too low isn't it nice
- why would I even want to climb that
reason are you talking about Petey come
on go home you're drunk
it may be drunk better days I don't trip
I got Jamie alright I think we're safe I
think we're fine I think we're having a
mighty good time I have no idea if we're
in the right place or not what was that
okay we're almost back just take it easy
Oh God not the alligator Oh God anything
but the alligator hater skater it's
quiet too quiet you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oops
they started long long long ago didn't
it who's knocking alright I need your
box you will assist me in this great and
noble quest of me leeching ladders key
green asking sorry definitely I guess it
doesn't really matter
you're the square okay so we need
oh no oh no you know what nobody no I'm
fine being in here even though I hate
you okay stop stop please stop
that is pretty key man
what am I supposed to do I was fine
problem is I think we have to go where
he goes no he went into water what the
fray all right that means we're gonna
have to go where the key hole goes just
like my life oh [ __ ] oh god sheets my
worst enemy
I'm gonna have to go through that barrel
now aren't I hello these mushrooms they
look like Oreos but blue ones love it
hashtag love it oh god why did I say no
[ __ ] I better hide in the barrel oh shut
it his [ __ ] to the shat I just pooped my
diaper
call me teddy hold me [ __ ] I can't hold
him when I'm crawling oh god oh god oh
god oh god okay don't let down look
okay let's say I got this I got just not
a baby I'm a man
I think can you kill me I don't want him
to kill me I'm a nice baby what is that
oh no ma yeah okay
bath egg what's going on here the same
where is the blue key I had the key but
I need to see oh god I don't know where
to hide oh god I don't know where to
hide here
what the Frick
don't play games I don't play games no
I'm not and I don't play it okay man to
[ __ ] up and I hope the bear
you're my only friend bear you know that
right Gandalf it's been cheating oh god
I don't like this
you know Gandalf has not been very nice
to me so I'm so glad you came along
teddy
I really believe that we have something
special
all right why are we supposed to go
I think this way Danny all right Danny
huh edson that's probably fine all right
I'm gonna have to crawl otherwise we'll
never get there
nothing gets over here it would make a
lot of sense cause it kind of looks like
a Jess
a little olive lots mmm I like when you
do that it's very hot
oh god he's coming isn't he mother of
[ __ ] I'm not even gonna pay attention
go go go go go go go go go go go oh god
oh god oh yeah
ah ah ah gah gah gah gah gah gah gah
lady got a little Gaga okay big guy go
ahh
now what are you doing it again no I'm
stuck I'm stuck nice I'm stuck help oh
my god what a man so drunk I'm so drunk
oh okay Gaga Lady gaga
Oh God a lady Gaga [ __ ] Lady
Gaga man Oh God Lady Gaga lady oh oh oh
oh oh oh dude you don't be messing with
me ho ho ho ho oh [ __ ] oh wait maybe he
was the alligator I went along I would
actually make sense you know oh god is
he coming no I don't have anywhere to
hide ya bet ya ah yo yeah ah I broke my
neck dankel ankle okay I got to last
Paso Pass okay go go get it girl go get
a girl my god I'm so [ __ ] done with
that place [ __ ] that place man [ __ ] dad
blaze in the face
for that place in the face go [ __ ] up a
sin the sorry okay let's get going
wallah me a little
that's a [ __ ] ugly shape man
this place pretty epic gotta hand it to
myself
I mean the developers sorry I don't like
to take tried to front of the people for
him but they probably took it right out
of my inspiration let's be honest I'm
just kidding that was a waiting room
ah [ __ ] I thought we would be done with
this place Teddy I need a hug
thank you I love you well let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
I don't even know why I'm going here out
of all places this kind of right here so
I attract me this is candles candles
candles candles everywhere
nope can't go there
oh [ __ ] no I thought we were done with
this
Oh is he trying to get maketh no I don't
like that what is this problem God get
her dog can a man be a baby for once in
his life can I drown my jammy
are you doing in gang you know no one
likes to rank the only likely because
you're Pablo I'm sorry don't look no he
gave me the puppy eyes oh god he's there
oh god I didn't think he spawned yet
there must be some way to cross this
battery and we will find it we shall
find it Michelle
find Michelle what
why did I do that there we go we found
it
what's that Alex is spacious I'm better
check it out
okay climb all right better just crawl
all our asses to it church is that it no
I didn't does it look like it
Oh God oh where where where where where
I don't go it freaks me out man he
freaks me out
I don't not know like no likey get in my
way chair awaits my [ __ ] time don't
you know who I am
yep you're the great Mary Pat yes I am
god damn could have an audit I'm kind of
busy all right Oh God Oh God no job no
go in go in see what you did see what
you did
god damn I nearly died for a goddamn
share Oh God yes what they had not dug
far before it started to rain without
climb out or they'll be trouble again
see the little bunny is climbing out of
the hole [ __ ] what is my life
spelt I had let me get in I'm a man I'm
a made man man one more memory girl one
more memory
all right res sorry sorry sorry sorry
but we're gonna have to end the episode
there but we'll see you tomorrow as
always so don't cry you are don't care
it's okay I love you that's for you
that's for you
double set Wow